it is great to be joined today by
christian picciolini who's founder of
the free radicals project host of
breaking hate on msnbc also author of
the book white american youth and his
story of leaving
neo-nazism and white supremacy is would
be fascinating to us at any time
christian but it is particularly
interesting and relevant given a lot of
what's been going on in the united
states for the last couple years so
maybe we'll start with your story i mean
you got into the movement pretty young
at 14 i believe how did that happen
what's the genesis of it
yeah and david thanks for having me on
um i was recruited when i was 14 years
old in 1987. i was very early uh in you
know kind of this version 1.0 of the of
the white nationalist movement that
we're calling it today
uh i was a neo-nazi skinhead in fact
that was one of america's first um
you know what led me there essentially
was i think what leads every uh person
to this movement and and that was my
life's potholes uh those traumas i think
that kind of nudge us from our path
and lead us down you know pretty dark
corridors
for me
it was a lot of uh
you know abandonment issues low
self-esteem
uh my parents are actually italian
immigrants so it wasn't something i i
was raised with at home
but because my parents are immigrants
when they came over in the 60s they had
to work very very hard and i never saw
them so they were gone seven days a week
14 hours a day and i really struggled
with
uh you know thinking
what i had done uh you know had pushed
them away potentially and and i was
never
you know really brave enough or knew how
to ask or to communicate those feelings
so i i kind of went astray at a very
young age um searching for identity
community and purpose and and not really
being able to find it
until one day at 14 years old i was you
know standing in an alley smoking a
joint and this guy pulled up in a car
and he got out and he had a shaved head
and he was wearing boots and he walked
up to me and he pulled the joint out of
my mouth and he said that's what the
communists and the jews want you to do
to keep you docile and smoking pot will
keep you docile so that then they what
take over or control you or society
exactly yeah it was it was their method
of control over us one of you know one
of their many conspiracy theories about
you know how uh you know jews were in
power to control and destroy the white
race through multiculturalism and
uh you know
the feeding of drugs into white
neighborhoods and things like that i
mean it was ridiculous obviously looking
back now but at 14 years old for
somebody who you know had hit a wall as
far as acceptance over and over and over
again and was bullied and felt very
marginalized when this man who was
america's first neo-nazi skinhead walked
up to me
it was as if he was offering me a
lifeline i didn't understand anything
about the politics i didn't understand
you know racism it wasn't
it wasn't something i was
you know even aware of because i lived
in such a small
bubble
uh meaning my my family's home i didn't
really go out very much i was kind of a
very solitary kid um
so you know it it offered me kind of a
way to belong and and it didn't matter
what he was selling i think i probably
would have jumped at anything at that
point so what i mean what was being sold
in terms of what were sort of like the
key principles or you know
talk a little bit about so you you get
pulled in somehow you're either invited
to come to some
meetup or group or in some way you start
building these relationships what were
sort of like the predominant themes or
ideas that were being discussed
well i mean at first it was it wasn't
about any kind of ideological beliefs or
even themes it was about just drawing me
in because of uh you know my lack of
acceptance in the past the savvy
recruiter uh you know and recruiters in
general recognize that that i was
vulnerable because of
uh you know my loneliness my
marginalization and they essentially
swooped in and offered me paradise and
then the types of things that they would
start talking about started off fairly
benign they would uh you know this man
who saw me in the alley actually after
he snatched a joint from my mouth
and said that you know went on to ask me
what my uh name was and i told him and
he recognized it was italian and then he
started to praise uh you know italian
and roman civilization as being uh you
know
great thinkers and warriors and and
artists and that i should be proud of
that
and you know being an italian kid
growing up in an italian neighborhood
with you know fully italian parents i
knew all about that stuff so i was very
proud of that
but then when he started to um you know
after he pulled me in through this sense
of pride then he started over time to
try and
say that people were trying to take that
pride away from me weren't trying to
diminish it and then of course went on
to name the groups of people and it
started with uh you know jews who who
wanted to manipulate and control you
know that was his his conspiracy theory
uh that african americans were uh you
know were lazy and only uh good for
selling drugs and crime and that they
were destroying our neighborhoods uh
which you know my neighborhood was
changing and i didn't see any of those
things but it seemed plausible to me at
the time what's interesting about that
christian is that there's this idea of
the fear of the loss of status right and
that underlies a lot of the resurgence
we're seeing in the last couple of years
around some of these ideas as well so
that that was a big thing you're saying
the fear of someone's going to take your
status from you
well well here's the thing i mean white
supremacists are very good at creating
the desperate conditions for people to
live under and then using those
desperate conditions to actually
create fear of them and place that blame
on somebody else so not only not only
are they creating the conditions but
they're feeding them constantly through
fear rhetoric and by blaming of the
other
and that's what's happening today i mean
we you know we hear things like
multiculturalism is is white genocide uh
that you know white males are
are being targeted as as uh
as you know the most evil people on
earth right now and and that their
identity is being taken away and you
know frankly none of that is is true uh
white males have done a lot of awful
things in our history and and i think it
deserves to be called out just like you
know other people have done awful things
uh you know in our history and
and uh it certainly doesn't paint a
whole species as as bad uh however um
you know the recruiters and and the
propagandists are very good at kind of
identifying these very
simple um
kind of
controversial talking points like free
speech
or white civil rights or the fact that
you know they claim that people can't be
white and proud and they use all those
things to kind of
pull out
[Music]
essentially pull out the racism in
people that was dormant
by making them afraid of something that
could happen to them but is certainly
not happening
how does the line get crossed and maybe
it's not so much a line but it's a
blurry area into
violence and the stockpiling of weapons
for a potential race war like in your
path how does the transition happen from
where it's just here's a group where i
can kind of feel not like an outsider
they're welcoming me where i belong to
the ideas that you just told us and then
go beyond that into actual violence and
and getting weapons and preparing for a
race war
excuse me uh you know i think it's about
desperation and uncertainty
the more we you know we people get into
these uh extremist groups because most
times they're looking for acceptance
they're looking for identity they're
looking for purpose
and while they may find those things to
some degree in these types of movements
what it actually does is it further
marginalizes them from society
uh and you know i think if desperation
and uncertainty uh
you know grow to a point where
a person feels that there's nothing that
they can say or do that will
uh give them any acceptance or
you know any sort of um camaraderie or
identity then you know the potential is
there if there are underlying issues
like mental health issues or um
feelings of revenge uh that can't be
critically thought out you know then
sometimes it does lead to that but i can
tell you that you know there's this
this whole notion that
you know we're calling white extremists
or white terrorists mentally ill and
that we're not calling them terrorists
and i do agree with that i do believe
that we we have to call white extremists
who commit terror terrorists but at the
same time you know
it's also true that we do tend to paint
uh most white actors in this space as
people who are mentally ill versus you
know people of color who are doing this
as terrorists right off the bat the
truth is is that mental illness is
really the underlying factor uh not just
for white extremists but across the
board um
i tell you about 75 of the of the people
that i work with um are either living on
the autism spectrum or with asperger's
or schizophrenia or bipolar and i'd say
95 percent of those people are either
undiagnosed or untreated
and i think that a lot of that having to
live with that you know not only does it
cause social marginalization growing up
uh you know maybe they were looked at as
odd or strange or or somebody that you
know couldn't
they couldn't be friends with that
pushed them away and the combination of
all those potholes those traumas i think
is what leads people to that desperation
and that search for acceptance in really
negative pathways can you talk a little
bit about the conspiratorial element of
it because even in the conspiracy world
generally there is this disproportionate
appeal as i think you say
to individuals who are struggling with
different emotional or mental illness
type conditions where they have maybe
slightly more of a propensity to be
pulled into some of these ideas and one
of the sort of hallmarks of
conspiratorial thinking is that both
evidence for and evidence against is
evidence for right the fact that there
is a piece of evidence that seems to go
against your conspiracy is part of the
conspiracy right either because it's
planted evidence or whatever we all kind
of understand how that works
does that take on a particular dynamic
within the world of white supremacy in
other words the idea that uh if you have
a counter example about jews aren't
really conspiring to do this or that
well that's part of the conspiracy
they're making you think that they're
not conspiring how do you even deal with
that type of thing
i don't i don't ever debate with anybody
about ideological topics i you know i
listen a lot
and and i i'm able to filter out that
noise of those conspiracy theories maybe
it's because i you know for eight years
of my life i used to say them and now i
they sound you know utterly ridiculous
to me
uh so i'm able to kind of tune in uh and
focus in on on those potholes like what
really led them there is it abuse is it
you know trauma is it mental illness is
it poverty is it extreme privilege
whatever those things are though that's
what i'm listening for i try not to to
engage you know into an illogical debate
even if i am using logic because it just
doesn't penetrate it has to be kind of
an emotional connection uh but to answer
your question i mean i think
you know there are certain aspects and
characteristics of people living with
certain disorders that that would uh you
know kind of foster unidimensional
thinking or a hyper focus on something
or a natural lack of empathy um and you
know and and i think the structure of
the movement the structure of these
conspiracy theories is very appealing to
people
uh who you know maybe see outside
stimuli uh as you know kind of like
noise that they can't uh settle
um
so you know this the rigid structure of
very black and white thinking the you
know the facts that are presented uh or
sorry the conspiracy theories that are
presented as fact
kind of provide some comfort i think to
people who uh you know might have um a
lot going on in their head that they
don't understand and uh it draws them in
it provides some answers to them
and you know it's i think conspiracy
theories are are what are driving these
movements and they have for you know
decades and decades
um you know and even centuries i mean
these tropes these kind of anti-semitic
tropes and
and uh you know
garbage science about you know race and
iq and and uh you know
ideas about
identity and misogyny things like that
are all you know part of these movements
and uh you know what scares me the most
though david is today
there are people out there very you know
famous podcasters and and writers of
books with new york times bestsellers
who are pushing these same types of you
know identity and
junk science tropes that are so
consistent with the white nationalist
movement that either willingly or or
sorry wittingly or unwittingly are
spreading these it's causing so much
damage and leading so many people
towards this movement that i'm not even
sure that they're aware they're doing it
yeah that's actually exactly what where
i want to pick up the conversation in
part two of the interview we've been
speaking with christian petrolini who's
founder of the free radicals project
host of breaking hate on msnbc and also
author of the book white american youth
and that's exactly where we'll continue
our conversation on tomorrow's program
we're continuing our conversation with
christian picciolini who's founder of
the free radicals project host of
breaking hate on msnbc
also author of the book white american
youth so in part one of the interview
christian we talked about how you got
into the neo-nazi skinhead movement and
some of the sort of characteristics of
folks that are particularly drawn to it
and targets for recruiters
before we get into how you got out of
the movement i'd be interested in
hearing a little bit about how you see
what's going on today we had the one
year anniversary recently of the
charlottesville virginia rally that led
to the death of one woman and many
injuries a rally about which the
president of the united states said
there were very fine people on both
sides including the side that included
neo-nazis and white supremacists do you
see
the current resurgence as directly
connected to who's in the white house or
is it more complicated than that
i think it's slightly more complicated
than that but i will say that
you know
the election did
uh kick over a bucket of gasoline that
was already that kind of ignited all the
small fires that already existed around
america
um you know i i certainly think that uh
you know we can refer to the statements
made by the white nationalists
themselves uh from david duke to richard
spencer to matthew heimbach to you know
many of the prominent leaders within the
white nationalist movement who came out
and said you know we've elected our man
you know we're excited about the
policies that he's implementing uh you
know from building a wall to a muslim
ban to uh you know tearing uh families
uh away from each other and deporting
them
these are all these are all white
nationalist talking points and they were
thrilled uh when uh trump was elected
president um
you know hate crimes have have been up i
mean the statistics are all there the
facts uh you know can't be ignored and
certainly some of the policies and the
words that he's used himself can't be
ignored so uh you know i i certainly
think it has fueled uh i don't know if
we'd call it a resurgence but it's it's
certainly uh it's bigger but it's it's
more that it's come out of the shadows
than it was trump did not create racism
my sense has been that there's not so so
much
more or new
white supremacists and neo-nazis but
there's more comfort in just kind of
saying that those are your views and in
demonstrating publicly do you agree or
do you think that there's actually
individuals who are entering the
movement as a result of what's going on
oh i think there are absolutely more
people entering the movement as a result
oh you do that's much worse than i was
hoping
well there you know the tactics have
changed and the platforms uh with which
they they reach people have have changed
so i think the internet is really
uh it's kind of like my digital alley
right uh you know for so many young kids
you know kids who feel marginalized
rather than going to smoke pot in an
alley like i did are now going to hang
out in chat rooms and in forums and uh
you know places like 4chan and reddit
and in those places they're starting to
see these very kind of benign uh you
know white nationalist recruiting uh
lures
uh like i saw you know things about
identity politics and and uh you know
black on white crime statistics that are
falsified and and even skepticism
towards the holocaust so it's not you
know the new wave of this kind of
pseudo-intellectual pseudo-philosopher
thinking that's influencing so many
young people both on the internet and in
real life you know they're they're not
calling themselves holocaust deniers
they're not calling themselves white
nationalists they're skeptics they're
scientists uh they're philosophers who
are just searching for the truth and
that's the way they hide uh you know the
racism and the ideas that they're trying
to push and so many people david are
falling victim to this and they're not
white not all of them yeah well that's
what i wanted to kind of ask about
because you mentioned the idea of people
who don't even realize that even if they
don't consider themselves part of any of
these movements by their mere sort of
acceptance of some of the ideas they're
becoming and this isn't an insulting
term it's a term that has a specific
meaning a useful idiot right someone who
is
without being aware of it serving a
particular purpose that they're not even
necessarily connected to what are some
examples of that
well yeah no i mean i think useful idiot
is a really great way to put it it's an
intelligence term that means somebody's
been compromised without really their
knowledge and they're being put to use
without knowing what they're doing uh
you know and i think a lot of uh you
know famous uh writers people like
jordan peterson or podcasters like sam
harris and certainly uh you know these
kind of pseudo uh philosopher types like
stefan molino from canada uh
you know are very good at hiding uh the
fact and again whether it's intentional
or not i don't know they could be useful
idiots although i would say that molino
is is very uh well aware of what he's
doing and the other two may not be
uh they're pushing these ideas that are
uh gateway drugs essentially to white
nationalism when they start talking
about skepticism of the holocaust uh or
the fact uh you know based on the bell
curve charles murray's bell curve that
uh you know whites and asians have a
higher iq uh because of genetics than
than africans and and uh other people of
color no christian music i know because
i haven't heard of the people you
mentioned peterson harris and molyneux
which which ones are doing the holocaust
skepticism because that i genuinely
haven't heard from them
so stefan molino has several videos um
where he's talked about it where he's
you know he's freight and he's from
canada too so he has to be very specific
about what he can and can't say about
the holocaust because uh denying it
there is part of their hate speech laws
and he can be arrested uh but you know
he's he's towed the line he's come to it
and posed the question uh you know did
did it you know i'm not quoting uh but
did it happen you know he kind of
elicits people to think on it
kind of with the notion that perhaps it
didn't um you know i can't tell you how
many parents i get emails from that say
you know i've lost my son or my daughter
to stefan molino uh you know there was a
point where he was
encouraging his his millions of
followers uh to defu their parents and
dfu stands for to uh to remove yourself
from your family of origin yeah because
he thought that that you know parents
were inherently uh you know awful uh for
the development of children i suspect he
probably had a really bad situation you
know in his childhood that made him
believe that but certainly i would i
would argue that you know parents are
not awful for children unless the
parents are awful people um but
you know and he's always kind of
shape-shifting into this very
nationalist uh you know very kind of
white nationalist uh viewpoint i mean
even so far as david duke praising him
and retweeting him and and
and things like that so he'll deny it
until he's blue in the face but uh you
know i can tell you that for somebody
like me those aren't dog whistles those
are bull horns i hear those things loud
and clear because i used to do the same
thing i used to mask my true intentions
and and make the words a little bit more
palatable for people to swallow so that
i could recruit them so that i could put
my ideas in their head and essentially
bait them so i could reel them in later
and you know unfortunately i think so
many of their listeners of molino and
harris's and
and even peterson's readers uh are
falling victim to these ideas that are
just really garbage science and and very
racist in nature so you've talked a lot
about
how
the pulling into the movement happens
either through the sort of useful idiot
stuff or direct recruiting as you were
directly recruited when you were 14 can
you talk now a little bit about how you
get out and maybe start with you i mean
what what started to turn for you that
you eventually got out of the neo-nazi
skinhead movement
well you know
having been
born with racism not a part of my dna
certainly helped i mean i for every day
of those eight years that i was involved
i questioned my involvement
unfortunately that what i was getting
from it in terms of you know this
perception of power and his perception
of strength i started to become really
intoxicated with with it
and nothing that presented itself even
though it was better was was powerful
enough to to draw me away until i
started to actually meet the people
that i thought i hated i had opened a
record store in 1995
to sell white power music because that
was the world that i lived in i was in a
band and was really all i knew since i
was 14.
and uh but i also sold hip hop and punk
rock and heavy metal to make ends meet
and you know i started to meet
african-american people and jewish
people and gay people and muslims and
and all of a sudden
uh not all of a sudden but you know over
time at the store i had to deal with
these customers i began to
realize that you know i had much more in
common with them than i did with the
people i'd surrounded myself with to
boost my own ego
and it was really the compassion that
these people showed me even though they
knew exactly who i was and what i was
about and what i was selling in my store
they came in and chose to treat me with
compassion
and it was the compassion that i
received from them one uh you know the
people at least deserved it from when i
least deserved it i think that was my
most powerful uh catalyst for change i
just couldn't reconcile my prejudice the
demonization that i had for these people
now that i've met them and had a
meaningful engagement with them was
destroyed and it became you know turned
into humanization and i just couldn't
deny
um the truth anymore so
did you talk about that with the other
neo-nazis skinhead people that you were
around did you say you know i'm starting
to kind of question or was that was that
an internal dialogue exclusively
oh it was internal uh because you know
there was always a fear of of seeming
weak or
being vulnerable within the movement you
know it wasn't something that
wasn't something that most people did uh
you know you're talking about a bunch of
uh you know type a
alpha males or people you know or males
who were trying to be that and uh you
know talking about your feelings and
your emotions wasn't always a good thing
unless it was about anger and violence
uh so i struggled with it internally
actually you know i struggled it for the
last two years i was in the movement and
i still couldn't leave
even though i was uh you know it was
devastating me uh devastating me so much
that i lost my wife and my children
because of it because i didn't leave the
movement fast enough for them they were
never involved
uh and you know the lure of this kind of
identity community and purpose that i
had found in the movement was
was too strong and i didn't have the
courage to to walk away until you know i
hit rock bottom and then
i really had no choice and when you do
that is it a clean break is there i mean
is it easy to leave i don't this isn't
this is a poor analogy but we've
interviewed a lot of former
scientologists who say you don't just
leave right like i mean there's physical
things keeping you there there are
financial things keeping you there etc
can you just say i'm out and that's it
yeah i wish it were that easy but it's
not uh you know everything that i had
was invested in that movement uh you
know much like the story of the
scientologist and really you know
becoming a neo-nazi or becoming a part
of a white supremacist movement is
really not that different than a cult or
the islamic state or gang
or a sports team or a religious group i
mean
it was the same type of draw it was that
you know sense of belonging in the sense
of this is who i am and this is what i'm
supposed to do with my life
um so it was very difficult uh to walk
away from that because it was really
everything that i had ever known
and i had nothing to go back to
and the threat of you know leaving
certainly the physical violence was
always there but also the threat of not
being accepted by uh you know everybody
else once you left was was always a big
threat you know like drug users maybe
it's sometimes just easier to go back
and for many people it that's what
happens unfortunately if we don't
replace it with a new
identity community and purpose
and frankly my struggle getting out
which i you know i had to
i had to question myself for many years
i had to do a lot of soul searching i
had to make amends and seek forgiveness
uh when i eventually found the courage
to tell my story uh was a long process
and it's precisely the reason why i
founded the original organization uh
life after hate and also now free
radicals project was to actually help
people go through that that transition
and then it kind of morphed into
proactively uh you know inserting
ourselves to try and get people
disengaged
last thing i want to touch on in the
time we have left um there's sort of i
guess to use an analogy there's retail
and wholesale strategies for getting
people out of the movement so daryl
davis for example who we've interviewed
several times who's awesome he has more
of like a retail approach where he will
go and individually hang out with kkk
members and other neo-nazis etc the
southern poverty law center has what
they consider to be more of like a
wholesale approach where they are trying
to dismantle the groups from the top
down
given all options do you have strong
feelings about what the most effective
way is to disrupt or take apart these
groups
well i think uh both strategies are
important i think we do need to you know
have a wholesale or a preventative
strategy but we also have to to you know
treat the illness uh patient by patient
it's almost like polio right
you know we have to treat sick people
which is what daryl and i do to a large
degree
but we also have to inoculate the
population from getting sick which is in
large part what groups like the splc or
the anti-defamation league or many of
these other
um
groups that are are countering hate do
and i kind of do a little bit of both so
my goal is really to educate people um
you know through different mechanisms
like my talks the tv show breaking hate
uh to be able to show people what they
can do because i know that you know
people like me and daryl are are far and
few between
um but that we also can
that we can destroy
this type of interpersonal racism now
i'm not talking about systemic or
institutional because that's a whole
other thing that we need to tackle as
well if we want to see racism go away
but as far as interpersonal racism
you know this is something everybody can
do so long as we can start to understand
that ideology is not what is
radicalizing people uh the
pre-radicalization happens from the day
we're born and it continues through
every situation that we have until that
extremist group presents itself at which
point we're radicalized uh so my
pre-radicalization was fraught with
abandonment and and with low self-esteem
and confidence issues for some people
it's sexual abuse or uh you know mental
illness things like that that is though
all those points of marginalization
trauma those pain points that kind of
just nudges from our path that is the
radicalization process the ideology when
it presents itself is just the
permission slip and the license to be
angry uh and for and for some people uh
you know they're lucky enough to never
come across that that uh recruitment
point uh and they may go into drugs or
they may get into prostitution or they
may commit suicide it's all these other
kind of destructive behaviors but people
in hate movements hate people uh not
because of the color of their skin but
because they hate themselves they're
projecting their own pain onto other
people their own feelings of
of inadequacy of of
of you know whatever it is that's
troubled them
these groups have given them the
permission to project that pain onto
other people and for many of these folks
to feel good about themselves making
somebody feel worse than they do is
sometimes the only way they can do that
um so you know i would caution
but also i think it's hopeful that we
know that uh because if we know that
it's these things that happen to us
throughout our lives that cause us to go
into these extremist groups that that
essentially allow us to hurt other
people yeah we can fill those potholes
and fix
those people with better social services
with better mental health uh services in
states there are some states that don't
even have that kind of stuff i mean it's
terrible
sometimes to think how our system is
really not serving its citizens but
you know if we can
i think we can largely um i think we can
largely solve this issue of violent
hatred and and extremism if we can fill
those potholes
for kids at an early age
christian picciolini founder of the free
radicals project host of breaking hate
on msnbc and you can also check out his
book white american youth christian i
really appreciate you taking some time
to talk to me today
david it's my pleasure thanks for having
me